hello everybody and welcome to part 6 of
our flasks in general web development
tutorial series in this video what we're
going to be talking about is we're going
to finish up this sort of main landing
page here and then we're going to talk
about the real crux of this my website
at least and I'll just bring it over and
that's the dashboard so that's this here
so one of the main reasons I even
switched from WordPress to flask was I
just had too many topics and it was
organized in just this big list of links
at the top of the page and that's
obviously really messy and I even knew
what content I had available and
sometimes I would it would take me a
while to like find it in that list of
links it just got to be too many so I
have over 700 tutorial videos and I
don't even know how many topics but a
lot and so it just got a little too
messy so what we've got here now is the
stash bar we've got these pages and tabs
which you can the tabbing and all the
the JavaScript fade and all that that's
all bootstrap and so we've got all these
topics and you'll see that you know web
dev has four topics relating to web dev
then we've got data analysis where we've
got one two three four five six seven
seven total topics and then even in
let's say data analysis you've got
machine learning which has another one
to three topics you see how how it could
get really confusing really fast if we
had all the topics just right at the top
so I knew I wanted to organize it like
this again all this is bootstrap stuff
and so I knew that how I wanted to do it
was to organize like this and then the
only other major thing I knew that I
wanted to have was full editing rights
so generally even like WordPress to
insert say a script like Java Script
it's actually kind of you have to do it
kind of a little bit of a hacky way
about it you do have mostly HTML rights
but not full HTML rights and so it just
gets kind of messy and then I do like
the content management system although
it takes a lot of processing to pull
from a it takes a lot of power basically
to pull from a database especially if
you have a lot of visitors
so since its inception at least in so
far and probably in my short-term
conceivable future I am the only
administrator on Python programming net
therefore I didn't really see any reason
to make an ACP especially when I had
wanted to have full rights to be able to
insert things like a JavaScript watch
this is bright on a breath on editor and
do all kinds of stuff like this and just
all of this stuff I knew that I wanted
to just be able to write HTML so then at
that point it became well why do I even
need an ACP we can just use literally
HTML files that are templated files
which is what an ACP would do for you
and so we'll talk a little bit more
about that about the organization but
it's actually a lot easier than I think
most people you know most people want to
make an ACP and it's really not
necessary especially if this is just a
simple website that only you own and
control so anyways enough about that
let's go ahead and start to make this
and in the creation of this dashboard is
basically where we're going to have a
lot of logic we're going to have some
information as far as on the user so
like this this this is a progress bar
basically I've done all the tutorials
I'm on the main account right now and so
after I write them I usually go through
them so the progress is 100% on
everything but it's a it'll track you
personally going through basically all
of the toss so like you've got just
general data data manipulation and then
you've got just like the actual
tutorials itself and so each time you
finish a tutorial you'll get a little
notch on the bar so I knew I wanted to
do that as well so we'll have that we'll
have checks on the user itself this is
also varied this is dynamic it'll be
yellow if you haven't done in so on so
anyway the organization for this is also
done pure Python logic this is one of
the reasons I just I think it's really
cool to use a Python web framework as
opposed to say WordPress because you can
do a lot of stuff and you'll understand
your own system more than someone else's
system most likely so anyways let's go
ahead and hop into it so this is our
main page we're just going to finish it
up with a quick embedded video so we're
just gonna embed that video right
between
two body tags so to get the video let's
just go to Python program Nets homepage
and control you to be the source
scroll down to you find the video tags
here we are and it links to dashboard
and then we're also gonna we're just
going to take this whole div right here
so it's this div a container align
Center this one's height is eighty
percent so I wanted to make room for
that little button but we'll change that
in a moment
anyway take that will copy it and we'll
paste it right in this is actually video
tags are part of html5 so that you don't
really need to do anything more with
them and you'll notice that I have muted
the video it is on autoplay and then you
can also with the video embed it and
better see it's a video but we don't
really have any controls okay but you
can add controls to the bottom it that's
also built-in you don't need any plugins
or anything like that that's just part
of html5 so anyway we'll save this we'll
get rid of Python program net before we
start thinking that's our development
page refresh and there it is if you
don't have I should have stayed on
Python programming dead actually if you
don't have these files which you
probably do not what you'll do is just
go to Python program at and then again
we can view the source come on down to
where the video is control click this
one this one this one we'll just have to
copy and paste basically take this come
over here
append it to the URL and now you've got
the image then you've got one of the
videos so you just right click save
video as and then the other video the
WebM video right click save as and if
you have all these is basically the
source so if you put WebM first it'll
play the WebM above the others and if it
can't like so if you visit my website on
your phone for example it's just going
to show you the image so it's not going
to waste your your time downloading the
mp4 or the WebM on your phone so now
you've got that I think that you know we
can come back to this home page and talk
about some more HTML stuff I don't know
about you but I'm getting tired of
talking about HTML so we're going to
move on to the dashboard and actually
get into flask and probably the more
interesting topic
for my viewers so anyway a little close
out of this stuff and let's get started
with the dashboard now so when we click
on this it heads to the dashboard but we
have it we get a not found because we
haven't coded anything for the dashboard
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to write some code that will head
us to something when the user goes to
the dashboard let me make my text big
and we've opened up in it dot pi and
basically we'll just take this right
here we'll just copy that this is
basically the same kind of stuff you'll
always use anyways paste and now instead
of slash nothing we'll do / - bored now
um I guess I'll show you guys something
really quick so let's just save this and
let's come over here and service Apache
to restart whoops
restart so we'll restart Apache uh let
me find where is the this no oops that's
still Python program net let's open up
the one we were this one okay so we've
got dashboard and so that was oh well
let's make it return something a little
a little custom so dashboard and instead
of the instead of return render template
for now we're gonna have it just return
a string for us just cuz I want to show
you something return hi save let's
restart Apache one last time refresh
we're getting an internal sort o it's
cuz we okay first of all every time you
if you do copy and paste these functions
just understand that you have to always
have a custom name to that function even
though it doesn't really have any other
meaning
besides that let's do this one more time
okay so dashboard slash not found let's
take away the slash and it's found okay
now let's change this so this was the
app root was slashed dashboard no slash
now we add a slash save that restart
Apache come over here
refresh it still works and you'll see it
added the slash for us so let's do it
one more time adds the slash and of
course if you
have the / you're totally fine so just
understand I think the best thing to do
is go ahead and write everything with
the slash in it because that way that
never becomes a problem for me coming
from WordPress all of my links like in
Google and stuff had that slash and it
was giving I set up something to track
whenever someone would get a 404 it
would save it and I can show you guys
how I did that too
it would just save that so I could view
the file and see what people were 404
hang on you can do the same thing for
errors and log all the errors that users
get and all kinds of information I was
doing that and I was seeing that that
was constantly in trouble so anyway just
just add them there and that way both
versions of links will land the user on
a page you can also have multiple links
so for example this is a promote
dashboard you get at another decorator
right on top and you can call this slash
board save refresh that and dashboard
still works slash board works as well
and it will return the exact same thing
so for whatever reason that I've found a
few why you might want to very different
URLs you can still do that so we've got
dashboard and now we want a new template
in that template is going to be just a
dashboard template now so return and
we'll call this literally dashboard die
HTML we can say well just oh well that's
not going to return us anything so we
don't have any dashboard at HTML right
so we'll come into templates now right
click new file here and we'll call this
one dashboard dot HTML but we also want
to have let me just put a space and save
this so it'll actually save we also want
to have a new file and that one's going
to be header dot HTML and head about
HTML space and save is going to contain
the stuff that is traditionally known as
a header so that will contain the top
nav bar and any footer if we so choose
to have one so for now we're not going
to worry too much about the footer I
just want to keep us away from
any additional HTML footers fairly easy
in the way that I've done it at least on
Python programming dotnet is the
following so we go over here you do I do
have a footer it's literally footer tags
just a tag that has footer in it and
then it's 100% so let me go to robotics
let's do this see if I can find one that
doesn't have it's hoping to find one
let's see and go robotics I had one
maybe it was one of these that was not a
full page anyway is what I'm looking for
yeah so here's an example so I don't
like pages that have footers on the page
like where it's like on the page always
I just hate it so I wanted a page that
had all the content here but if the user
so chose to scroll down usually in
search of a footer they would find a
flirter and so most of the tutorials
have so much stuff that they push the
footer down anyways but on some of them
they don't and so all you have to do is
we can view the source and we can go
down to our body which was here go to
the top body you've got border row cool
Google but here's where the main crux is
so container fluid style minimum height
is a hundred percent so it's a hundred
percent of the page that's the minimum
height of this body so that's how you
can keep it off the screen just for
anyone who's curious and then of course
like I was saying with the footer you
literally after the body
we've got div it's a footer container we
add a background color to it which is
that dark grey and you've got literally
footer ID footer and that's all this and
it's just column stuff which is from
bootstrap so feel free to copy and paste
that if you really want it there I'm
gonna go ahead and just leave that
behind for now maybe we'll add that to
the very end or something but literally
it's just copy pasted column code from
bootstrap with list items and or lists
rather so uh so yeah I think I'll cut
off the video here and we'll continue on
with the next video and we'll be working
on actually will make our header file
and we'll make our dashboard extend from
the header file I'll show you a little
bit more
extends their and then I'll just we'll
be talking about some logic and the
actual system I built to basically be
our content management systems so most
of the time people use maybe my sequel
for a content management system I I
thought it was actually going to be a
little more complicated it was going to
use a lot more processing this website
actually I'm getting far more users than
I did even before and the processing on
this website is like ten percent of what
it was on WordPress and the reason why
is because WordPress content management
system everything is in the database its
efficient but it's still pulling from a
database which uses a significant amount
of RAM some processing not too much but
it was actually a fairly heavy website
whereas this one I actually don't even
need the five dollar digitalocean server
it's using even less than than that so
anyway um I like it it's better it gives
me all the options I could want it's
just as secure as any other method so
that's my custom content management
system which we'll be talking about so
anyways that might be interesting to you
guys it's at least some sort of a custom
system you can do a lot of stuff with
the fact that you can make custom
systems so stay tuned for that we'll be
talking more about that in the next
video as always if you have any
questions or comments please feel free
to leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support subscriptions until next time